you know it's funny you're talking about
being being able to move forward you in
the last year you've faced adversity and
you've continued to move forward is that
how you've applied to all the things
that have happened in the last year yeah
i think look things happen and i think
what happens kev is people don't focus
on all the positive
like whatever's happened to me over the
last year i'm so grateful for it i mean
i had uh five years of of an incredible
life in in partnership and also with my
daughters we learned so much and now we
have an opportunity to take that and
move forward and say you know what we're
so grateful for the last five years how
do we make the next five years better
because of lessons learned so i'm in a
great place i'm so grateful for where
god in in
in in the light has really put me in and
i'm really looking forward
mostly to see how my girls keep
developing biggest regret
you know it's funny um when it comes to
regrets
i i just think that there's things that
i look back kevin i go oh man i cringe
that was so stupid that was so silly but
everything happens for a reason and one
of the great things one of the reasons
i'm here this is all those things that
have happened and i think i've done a
good job of learning from my lessons and
then applying them in the future and so
like sinatra says no no regrets el
presidente is really all about mastering
what you do right and i'm really excited
about this campaign we're doing and
hopefully i can open the doors for other
people of color minorities latinos women
and it's the right time for that
anybody can be presidente anybody can be
president absolutely everybody should be
this is the age there's the golden age
for entrepreneurship and there's so much
opportunity out there that if you can
get up and hustle whether it's a high
side hustle or your main hustle
anybody can make it look if if a young
kid like me made it from miami because
of baseball and i was able to take that
and do other things it also gives me a
platform to do great things like this
and help out you know the next
generation of entrepreneurs
[Music]